[Music]  you have the wrong guy does he look like  he can fight come on bro  you okay  [Music]  yo what up y'all it's your boy cliff  coming at you live on the bus i actually  did take a little bit of martial arts as  a youth so i'm gonna try and grade this  fight as we're going  [Music]  [Music]  throughout my life  the ten rings gave our family power  if you wanted them to be yours one day  you have to show me you are strong  enough to carry them  you are a product of all who came before  you  the legacy of your family  you are your mother  and whether you like it or not  you are also your father  i told my men  they wouldn't be able to kill you if  they tried  glad i was right  pierce is the criminal  who murders people  be careful how you speak to me boy  start a new life  but i could never  escape his shadow  my son  you can't run from your past  [Applause]  is this what you  wanted you got this  thank you  [Music]  you